bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 24
février merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
comme chaque jour nous revenons sur
votre actualité locale avec nos invités
mais également les journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite les titres de
cette édition et ce week-end s'ouvre à
paris la 53e édition du salon de
l'agriculture à jouy en josas la ferme
de viltain se prépare pour l'événement
un rendez vous important auquel elle
participe pour la 28e fois et le salon
de l'agriculture s'apprête à ouvrir ses
ports je vous le disais sur fond de
colère des agriculteurs partout en
france ils se mobilisent et dénoncent
leurs conditions de travail et la
politique à laquelle ils sont soumis
pour nous en parler ce soir christophe
lerebours président de la commission
économique et élus de la chambre
d'agriculture d'ile-de-france et
christophe robin président des jeunes
agriculteurs du canton de saint-armand
enfin pau vides y en une entreprise élan
courtoise a reçu le trophée solution
climat lors de la dernière coupe 21 son
invention sa tête sagesse une station
électrique autonome destinés à des sites
isolés retour sur le projet dans notre
chronique et le salon de l'agriculture
commence ce samedi 27 février plus de
1200 éleveurs sont attendues parmi eux
les équipes de la ferme de viltain qui
est située à jouy en josas l'entreprise
familiale connue pour ses produits
laitiers participent chaque année à ces
événements un moyen à cet événement
pardon un moyen pour eux d'aller à la
rencontre de leurs clients particuliers
ou entreprises mélanie poté et camille
lambert
cette année normalement devrait avoir
deux ou trois petits veaux notamment en
cette couleur-là et un de cette couleur
là encore on a une
un petit veau qui a une couleur marron
c'est la même race d'après mme stein
l'idée c'est que voilà on a des gènes de
temps en temps des petites surprises des
bonnes surprises comme celle là avec
avec des olives aux marrons leurs
troupeaux produits 3.5 millions de
litres de lait par an la ferme de
viltain on transforme 30% au fromage
blanc lait de consommation et un yaourt
en octobre dernier l'entreprise
familiale se dote d'une nouvelle
laiterie elle souhaite atteindre le
million de yaourt par an en fonction des
clients on peut avoir un client qui va
avoir quatre cuisines centrales en ile
de france
on va toucher 150 communes je savais que
ce client là on va avoir en ligne de
l'est
jusqu'à 9000 litres qui passent dans la
laiterie à la journée ça c'est un
objectif qu'on s'est fixés dans le
développement de la laiterie
donc il n'est pas encore atteint
évidemment mais ça peut être ça peut
être un pic qui attend en fonction des
gens ces produits vendus au marché de la
ferme seront présentés à la porte de
versailles le salon de l'agriculture est
un moyen pour eux de se faire connaître
du particulier comme du professionnel
pour nous c'est une grande force
on va avoir une visibilité qui est très
grande
on accueille des milliers de spectateurs
sur notre stand soit par la vente de
produits locaux
donc nos produits soit par des petits
jeux qui sont sur place la ferme de
viltain sera parmi le millier
d'exposants présents sur le salon
celui ci ouvre ses portes le samedi 27
février
les vo vous attendent jusqu'au dimanche
6 mars et cette 53e édition du salon de
l'agriculture qui je le rappelle se
déroule du 27 février
oui jusqu'au 6 mars s'ouvre sur fond de
colère des agriculteurs
dimanche 21 février au soir plusieurs
dizaines d'éleveurs en colère ont
manifesté devant le domicile du ministre
de l'agriculture stéphane le foll au
moment et partout en france les
agriculteurs crient leur détresse alors
qu'en est il pour les agriculteurs en
ile-de-france pour nous en parler ce
soir en plateau avec moi deux invités
christophe lerebours bonsoir vous êtes
le président de la commission économique
et élus à la de la chambre d'agriculture
ile-de-france et christophe robin
président bonsoir des jeunes
agriculteurs pour le canton de
saint-arnoult dans les yvelines
vous êtes également tous les deux vous
éleveurs de volailles et agriculteur
céréalier et quelques mendiants alors
aujourd'hui la colère des agriculteurs
vient du fait qu'ils ne peuvent plus
survivre vivre de leur profession on
peut le dire je pense je m'adresse
d'abord avoue christophe lelu rebours
est ce que voilà c'est une question de
prix imposées qui sont trop bas qui est
un petit peu là le bilan de toute
situation
si vous voulez aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans une grande problématique c'est que
dans les années 90 on a demandé à
l'agriculture française de rentrer dans
le marché mondial qui étaient les
accords du gatt à l'époque donc
aujourd'hui le les produits qui sont
donc nos céréales sont
directement impactés par un cours
mondial donc malheureusement la france
ne pourra pas agir sur les cours
mondiaux qui sont extrêmement bas depuis
deux ans simplement c'est que nos
grandes revendications aujourd'hui
depuis depuis lui dirai quatre ans était
d'une baisse des charges très
importantes au niveau français alors que
ce soit des baisses de charges au niveau
social ce soit des baisses de charges au
niveau fiscal que ça soit des mesures
environnementales beaucoup moins
strictes pour qu'on soit à peu près à la
hauteur de nos je dirais de nos
collègues européens notamment les
allemands les italiens les hollandais
pour qu'on ait je dirais des mêmes
d'armes pour nous battre et c'est ça qui
peine c'est que la france n'a fait aucun
effort depuis quatre ans et on est
aujourd'hui dans la situation qu'on
connaît actuellement situation
catastrophique accès pendant à la
réponse complètement là on peut
constater qu on a eu une baisse de 2 à
peu près 25% de nos aides pac et ça
impacte directement nos exploitations
agricoles et aujourd'hui on est on est
vraiment dans la crise puisqu'on voilà
enfin je te l'avais noté l'exemple d'un
jeune agriculteur qui s'étonne qu'ils
s'installaient sur une moyenne de 100
hectares en 2013
il va perdre 32 % de son revenu
disponible ces voix là et comme le
disait christophe vis-à-vis de nos
voisins allemands
on a un écart de dette de l'ordre de 150
euros ha donc c'est c'est quand même
très très important est-ce que vous
voilà vous êtes tous les deux aussi dans
la profession en ile de france
on voit beaucoup le problème surtout en
bretagne entend beaucoup parler ce qu en
ile de france
les agriculteurs sont aussi concernés
autant bah oui malheureusement c'est
pour vous donner quelques chiffres très
rapide il faut savoir qu'en ile de
france je dirais pratiquement un
agriculteur sur 10 gagnent moins de 4800
euros par an chiffres du ministère de
l'agriculture donc c'est une catastrophe
économique pour le monde céréaliers et
de monde je dirais de l'élevage le monde
du maraîchage parce que l'île de france
on est quand même je dirais plusieurs
plusieurs plusieurs agriculture on est
une agriculture c'est la lire notamment
bien sûr mais on a des maraîchers ne
faut pas oublier on a quelques élevages
encore notamment christophe qui fait de
volaille et donc les chiffres qu'on nous
donne aujourd'hui son son sont affolants
depuis deux ans nous avons
l'avant-dernière place au niveau des
revenus au niveau national c'est à dire
que on est à moins de 15000 euros par an
et alors que les limites des ministères
de l'agriculture considère toujours le
monde céréaliers comme comme je dirais
une agriculture sans problème alors que
c'est vraiment pas du tout le cas et ça
nous inquiète fortement au jour le jour
ce sont des problèmes voilà qu'elle vous
êtes confrontés bon alors si c'est reste
une marge de mon activité mais c'est à
la marge mais c'est vrai que c'est un
problème aujourd'hui est comment dire le
nombre d'agriculteurs sur l'île de
france représente afin de diversifier
dans des ateliers avec de l'élevage qui
représente un cinquième des
exploitations
c'est comment dire si aujourd'hui les
éleveurs de volailles sur le sur l'île
de france on est 10 % à peu près c'est
voilà aujourd'hui sur un atelier comme
le mien on est diversifiée on est proche
du public c'est c'est différent mais il
faut savoir que sur le débat sans fin
sur l'île de france il ya une baisse du
nombre d'un de de raréfaction des
acteurs de la filière des industriels
des abattoirs il ya l'aspect aussi
sociétal qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on
n'est pas forcément bien vue de la
population les odeurs les contraintes
voilà aujourd'hui c'est compliqué parce
que les gens ont des attentes au niveau
des de l'élevage et puis ils veulent pas
les contraintes donc c'est quand même
assez compliqué il ya un problème de
concurrence au niveau des prix au niveau
de la grande distribution c'est ça aussi
une des revendications des problèmes qui
ont été soulevés
alors bien sûr si vous voulez il faut
savoir que en france on distingue deux
grands secteurs on a le secteur je
dirais donc des céréales que je te que
je connais très bien la secteur qui a
organisé depuis pratiquement 60 ans où
je dirais toute la filière
c'est exactement des contraintes on sait
donc régir au niveau de notre filière la
problématique prix et donc on arrive on
arrive à se sortir de certaines
situations compliquées comme aujourd'hui
mais avec des difficultés mais on arrive
à gérer notre marché et après vous avez
le marché a viré de l'élevage marché
beaucoup plus
compliqué avec des abattoirs avec des
gens qui font qu'ils traitent le dirait
des produits avec des dénés des
négociants etc
et c'est un marché où qui n'est pas
encore complètement organisé et là le
nombre d'intervenants qui arrive dans ce
marché je dirais polluent le
je dirais la vision du coût réel que des
produits agricoles et les agriculteurs
n'arrivent plus à s'y retrouver des
éleveurs ne savent plus où par la marge
et c'est ça qui est compliqué pour eux
aujourd'hui c'est que tout le monde se
serre et les derniers à récupérer le peu
qui reste ce monde agricole et ça peut
plus durer
le président essaie des jeunes donc des
jeunes agriculteurs du conteneur certes
du canton de sainte aernoudt
quelques exemples le ressenti est ce que
vraiment il ya radouane dégel il ya de
moins en moins de jeunes qui osent se
lancer ou reprendre peut-être
il ya un ras-le-bol c'est clair par
rapport à tout ce que je viens d'évoquer
christophe sur les sur les courts sur le
feng shui on se pose des questions
aujourd'hui moi j'ai des jeunes qui
viennent me voir et me disent quand on
voit les cours des céréales
parce que voilà la dominante allait
quand même céréalière on se pose des
questions est-ce qu'il faut s'installer
parce que vous qu'en ce moment on a des
cours la grc plaisir suave tout à
l'heure c'était sans 330 euros la tonne
pour le pour le blé en couvre pas du
tout nos coûts de production quoi donc
ça voilà on se pose des questions alors
c'est vrai que l'agriculture a toujours
eu un vécu des crises donc faut savoir
regarder sur le long terme mais mais ça
n'empêche que moi j'ai des jeunes qui
sont qui s'installe encore sur sur la
filière élevage
donc faut rester faut rester courageux
et miser sur sur l'aspect local sur du
direct avec des clients de proximité
ça c'est une petite partie sert à un peu
un marché de niche meute est tout à fait
pas de pas trop tout miser là dessus
mais le gouvernement est alertée depuis
longtemps sur ces problèmes pour tourner
parce que ce qu'il propose justement
vous voyez des nouvelles aides qui ont
été proposées en fin janvier donc un
montant de 190 millions d'euros et le
diamant un plan plus vaste et une baisse
des charges sociales
est-ce que c'est suffisant ils pensent
mots
c'est les pansements aujourd'hui c'est
la filière entière qui est il ya un
problème structurel
aujourd'hui des fins d c'est pas
suffisant quoi c'est pas suffisant
faudrait revoir les choses aujourd'hui
on voit comme le disait christophe tout
à l'heure on travaille enfin joseph on
est tous sur des cours mondiaux
on est sur un an fin voilà on a on a on
a créé l'union européenne à l'origine
c'était pour la pac et on n'a rien fait
d'autre depuis donc on on a des
problèmes de distorsion de concurrence
on est on est on travaille pas enfin je
vois là quand tu le site est tout à
l'heure avec nos collègues européens
on est complètement à côté justement
pourquoi en allemagne ou en italie
les agresseurs s'en sortent mieux ils
ont réussi à mettre en place une
politique différente même sûr s'il
voulait lorsqu'on comprend l'impact ça
veut dire politique agricole commune
aujourd'hui elle n'a plus rien de commun
dans nos pays européens ça veut dire
qu'il ya des distorsions différence et
de concurrence à tous les niveaux donc
au niveau de nos z1 agriculteurs
allemands ne va pas voir les mêmes aides
caniguy culturel italien qu'un
agriculteur français ils vont pas avoir
les mêmes charges sociales donc et des
charges qui sont faramineuses au niveau
nationale française est par contre en
allemagne si vous voulez vous avez des
problèmes d'épaulé dès qu'ils viennent
travailler des roumains qui viennent
travailler 10 des distorsions de
concurrence sur des produits qui demande
beaucoup de main d'oeuvre notamment dans
l'élevage ou dans le maraîchage et puis
donc toute cette politique qu'il n'a
plus aucun sens au niveau européen eh
bien chacun joue le jeu de son propre
pays et la france a perdu de vue que
l'agriculture française était un secteur
très important de son économie et pense
qu'en mettant des pansements sur des
problématiques comme aujourd'hui ils
vont réussir à sortir l'agriculture
française dans l'ornière où elle se
trouve et c'est vraiment la plus grosse
erreur qu'on fait par exemple je vais
vous donner un simple exemple la le
ministre de l'agriculture annoncé une
baisse des charges sociales pour les
exploitations agricoles
c'est bien gentil simplement il faudrait
qu'on ait un revenu c'est exactement
pareil si on annonce une baisse des
impôts mais si personne ne gagne
d'argent et bien y'a rien à gagner et
donc aujourd'hui c'est trop tard même au
niveau je dirais si vous voulez le monde
agricole c'est ça toujours été comme ça
il ya eu des hauts il ya eu débat il eu
des bonnes années eu des mauvaises
années là on est dans le cycle des
mauvaises années il aurait fallu et ça
fait très très longtemps ça fait 25 ans
le demande à nos gouvernants c'est
lorsque et des bonnes années qu'on
puissent provisionner qu on puisse se
servir de cet argent pour justement des
années qui sont compliqués comme en ce
moment qu on puisse se servir de cette
trésorerie personne n'entend ce genre de
discours
c'est une catastrophique le gouvernement
fera de nombreuses personnalités
politiques vont profiter du salon de
l'agriculture qui s'ouvre en fin de
semaine pour venir voir les agriculteurs
c'est l'occasion de mettre en lumière
justement la situation des agriculteurs
est ce qu'on peut imaginer que va y
avoir peut-être des événements qui vont
se passer est ce que l'on peut
s'attendre après tu as des coups d'éclat
j'en sais rien aujourd'hui rien que j'en
sais rien c'est vrai que le salon ça a
toujours été une vitrine pour le monde
de l'agriculture
on a nos amis éleveurs qui sont plutôt
très concerné puisque il travaille tout
toute l'année pour présenter leurs bêtes
je ça me paraît compliqué de perturber
sa maintenant c'est vrai qu'il ya des
revendications donc je lui dirai
peut-être des événements quand même je
sais pas le pire c'est que en fin de
compte c'est un salon de notamment pour
les éleveurs ce soit les éleveurs
eux-mêmes qui prennent en charge je
dirais énorme leur mécontentement dans
ce salon qui est leur vitrine
et là on ne connaîtra pas le dire elle
afin de faire un mode histoire parce
qu'il peut y avoir des débordements qui
seront à contrôler à tout ce sont des
gens qui sont au bout du rouleau il faut
le savoir sont des gens qui ne qui sont
aujourd'hui en train de perdre leur
entreprise et qui n'ont même pas de
salaire à la fin d'année donc on ne vous
savez des gens quand ils sont au bout du
rouleau on sait plus trop comment ça se
termine à la fin
est ce que peut-être pas forcément son
agriculture mais après lurette d'autres
actions notamment en ile de france ou
sur paris justement des éleveurs
ile-de-france pour montrer leur colère
est consigné justement ces
revendications a par rapport au
gouvernement
on verra je aujourd'hui j'ai pas on a
pas on a pas plus d'éléments donc je pas
il devait y avoir une rencontre avec le
ministre délégué européen avec le
président donc pour vous mais
aujourd'hui on n'a rien de la france n'a
rien obtenu de bruxelles il faut savoir
que donc le ministère d'agriculture je
sais pas comment ils négocient niveau
européen mais bon a priori ça se passe
pas toujours très très bien il va
falloir surtout c'est que la france
arrête de je dirais de nous asservir
avec des normes qui sont complètement
délirante c'est à dire qu'on est le seul
pays européen à avoir des normes aussi
au dessus des normes européennes au
dessus des normes européennes ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui par exemple
christophe pour avoir un abattoir dans
son élevage c'est impossible pour
transformer des produits alimentaires en
france est impossible on a des normes
environnementales là par exemple si
jamais j'ai un maraîcher qui m'a appelé
qui m'a dit on ne peut plus faire de
nyon blanc en ile de france
parce que le ministère de l'agriculture
a décidé que le nom de blanc étaient
rattachés aux poireaux et donc du coup
une multitude de produits qu'on
utilisait pour faire de l'union blanc
comme eux on utilise partout en europe
eh bien peut plus le faire parce que il
y en a un qui a trouvé que le lion blanc
ça ressemblait à coire où on marche sur
la tête
merci merci messieurs peut d'ailleurs de
venir ne serait pas tout d'avoir répondu
à nos questions merci pour votre analyse
je le rappelle la 53e édition du salon
de l'agriculture peut être on vous
retrouvera ses du 27 février au 6 mars
tout autre sujet à présent parler santé
à l'occasion des vacances de l'est
peut-être en profiter pour aller chez le
coiffeur et sachez le la manière du coup
vos cheveux pourrait avoir une
répercussion sur votre bien-être
intérieur c'est en tout cas l'objectif
de la coupe de cheveux énergétique cette
pratique agirait sur la libération de
mémoire cellulaire du corps aux
clayes-sous-bois sophie lebouc pratique
la coupe énergétique de manière
professionnelle et elle a accepté de
nous ouvrir les portes de son cabinet
regarder je vais faire passer une
vibration en montant comme ça votre
cheveu c'est une méthode qui peut
paraître tiré par les cheveux mais ici
on les coupe plutôt en 4 soufi lebouc
pratique la coupe énergétique depuis
huit ans une technique de bien-être
psycho capillaire c'est premièrement
faire de la musique avec les cheveux
voilà et c'est rail sur la
déprogrammation cellulaire donc le
principe en fait de tendre les cheveux
donc les cordes et d'émettre une
vibration avec mes coupechoux les
couples où sont les lames utilisé par
soufi pour tailler les cheveux des lames
de 7 cm représentant sept notes de
musique par la vibration contact du
cheveu
cette vibration elle va aller aussi
contacter le cortex donc le cortex c'est
la membrane qui entoure les deux lobes
du cerveau ça passait par les oreilles
interne et ça va passer par le liquide
céphalo rachidien
c'est pour ça que ça des partis en fait
des techniques où le mental il peut pas
intervenir c'est le corps qui lâche qui
peut au moment où il peut le cheveu est
ici diriger un baromètre du court pour
calmer ou stimuler les organes c'est
vrai que le cheveu c'est le baromètre
justement parce que ils pompent le son
il se nourrit du sang donc bas suivant
si on est en carence si on un prêt ça
reprenne que le cheveu quand il ya un
problème au niveau d'un organe en habit
sert le cheveu lui c'est le premier au
courant parce que le sens il est vicié
et donc le cheveu lui il le sait déjà
j'ai détesté les coiffeurs longtemps
parce qu'ils vous vous écoute pas ils
vous entende pas quand je sors d'ici je
vais mieux
donc c'est quand même plutôt bien ce qui
devrait être l'ordinaire d'un coiffeur
mais ce qui n'est pas la coupe
énergétique une technique française
inventé par rebih portrait qui est pour
l'instant le seul à dispenser cette
formation une méthode basée sur l'écouté
du corps pour une meilleure harmonie et
bien-être
sentez toujours la peinture a pris ses
appartements à l'ehpad du
mesnil-saint-denis depuis la semaine
dernière
l'établissement propose depuis quelques
années déjà des expositions à ses
résidents ce mois ci c'est le peintre
mini luan michel pedro qui expose une
trentaine de ses oeuvres atteints de
sclérose en plaques depuis une vingtaine
d'années c'est pour lui une manière de
faire découvrir son art au public et
d'apporter également de la couleur aux
résidents un reportage signé camille
lambert un coup de pinceau qui
rappellerait presque celui des
impressionnistes il ne s'agit pas d'un
peintre du 19e siècle mais de michel
pédron sensible à la nature michel a
représenté le quotidien des fermes et
les animaux mais son tableau préféré
c'est celui du belem c'était une
commande
mon frère m'avait demandé donc de faire
une marraine aussi fn marine et comme
sue amoureux du bel m tu éphémère et
c'est sûrement pour ça c'est ce que je
préfère
je n'ai fait gonfler ont montré c'était
mère vraiment agité
j'ai aussi là mais je les fais un petit
peu trop forte mais s'ils étaient
volontaires atteints de sclérose en
plaques depuis une vingtaine d'années
michel pédron voit dans la peinture un
moyen de s'échapper
il a créé ses premières toiles en 1974
et à persévérer malgré une maladie
endommageant le système nerveux
l'ehpad le format noir lui servira de
salle d'exposition pour la première fois
pendant un mois
l'objectif rendre l'art plus accessibles
aux résidents dans notre établissement
les personnes dont beaucoup de
difficultés à se déplacer à sortir vers
l'extérieur et donc là c'est
l'opportunité finalement de faire venir
l'extérieur dans l'établissement ceux-ci
promouvoir des artistes locaux en fait
leur permettre d'exposer
dans notre résidence qui est quand même
un très beau bâtiment à cause de sa
maladie michel ne peint plus depuis 2013
l'un de ses derniers tableaux
représentent un portrait de son père
pour autant il ne souhaite pas
abandonner envisage même d'essayer de
peindre avec la bouche
l'exposition est ouverte au public
jusqu'au 13 mars
et en décembre dernier se tenait à paris
la coop 21 la conférence internationale
sur les changements climatiques à cette
occasion ségolène royal ministre de
l'environnement a remis les trophées
solution climat à trois pme l'une
d'entre elles povillon est basée à saint
quentin en yvelines et c'est mélanie
pompiers qui va nous en parler bonsoir
mélanésiens on sort floral alors ces
trophées récompensent et je cite les
meilleures solutions en matère matière
d'atténuation et ou d'adaptation aux
dérèglements climatiques pour médian
l'entreprise saint-quentinoise a reçu le
trophée dans la catégorie atténuation
leurs solutions primées s'appelle
sagesse pour smart autonomous brune
énergie station c'est jean-michel
bourget il est l'associé directeur
technique de l'entreprise qui en est à
l'origine
la station alors sagesse permet de
fournir de l'électricité à des sites
isolés actuellement dans le monde il
faut savoir que plus d'un milliard de
personnes n'ont toujours pas accès à
l'électricité
ce que ce soit pour des questions de
coût mais aussi d'isolement alors
sagesse fonctionne aux énergies
renouvelables
le vent et le soleil notamment elle est
complètement autonome et une puissance
de 100 à 200 kilowatts l'armée si un
jour par exemple mélanie n'y a pas de
vent il n'y a pas de soleil comment ça
se passe et ce que la machine fonctionne
quand même machine fonctionne quand même
parce qu'en fait sagesse stock de
l'électricité qui n'est pas utilisée
lorsqu'il y a des ressources
renouvelables
ça va être sûr ça va être stockés dans
une chaîne à hydrogène
mais le plus simple c'est d'écouter
pierre langers il est le président et
fondateur de poweo
il l'expliquera bienvenu que moi lorsque
cette énergie arrive on va commencer par
un électrolyseur un électrolyseur qui va
faire l'électrolysé de l'eau c'est quoi
l'électrolysé de l'eau l'eau vous savez
c'est h2o et d'oncle électrolyse de
l'eau c'est que l'énergie excédentaire
va permettre de casser de l'eau
c'est-à-dire entre à partir de ces un
petit réservoir d'eau qui est dans la
station on va en sortir de l'hydrogène
on va fabriquer de lille
aux gènes grâce à cette énergie
excédentaire au lieu de la perdre et
donc cette eau va se transformer en
oxygène et en hydrogène et c'est un
petit dreux gêne sera ensuite stockés
sur place dans des bouteilles ou des
réservoirs composite il restera inerte
aussi longtemps qu'on le souhaite et
quand le vent et le soleil ne seront
vraiment plus disponible c'est une pile
à combustible qui fournira l'électricité
alors lune et ses machines est déjà
installé on la trouve notamment en haute
montagne dans un refuge dans le parc de
la vanoise en savoie et c'est plus
précisément au refuge du code de calais
alors à l'image on va voir
l'installation de sagesse le refuge lui
est situé à 2600 mètres d'altitude dans
un site sauvage c'est la première
installation de l'entreprise chez nous à
saint quentin en yvelines pour médian
est présente sur le site d'airbus
défense space au parc d'activités piste
alou d'elancourt alors si au début elle
était rattachée à airbus
la société en elle-même a été créé en
2014 l'année 2015 a été l'année de la
création de la structure de la création
de l'équipe de l' embauche des personnes
puisque nous avons embauché en un an
treize personnes et que nous avons mis
au point qu'on commençait bien progressé
dans l'industrialisation de la solution
passer d'un prototype à une solution
opérationnelle
alors est ce que la machine stage est
peut être installés chez des
particuliers pour moment non ça
s'adresse surtout aux entreprises et aux
collectivités ça peut même être adapté
au monde militaire comme au monde civil
et le prochain chantier de pour idiots
floral ce sera au coeur du cycle de
mafate à la réunion merci beaucoup mais
la nuit pour ces informations on passe
tout de suite à la culture avant de
refermer ce journal avec un prêt après
un premier succès avec le loup est
revenu la compagnie nomadesk pour fils
ou n'en veulent avec le chat botté une
pièce jeune public revisité pour
l'occasion il était au théâtre espace
coluche de plaisir lundi 22 février pour
une représentation scolaire sauf et
c'est fort à damas nie pas remis et
fanny bourdon
berba joyeusement durness le chat botté
ce conte de charles perrault fait
l'objet d'une nouvelle adaptation drôle
et décalé l'histoire est respecté mais
de nombreuses variantes théâtrale mêlés
à des effets vidéo et ombres chinoises
font revivre ce conte de 1695
c'est vraiment histoire du chat botté
qui est un petit peu un petit peu
arrangé elle sauf que la princesse à la
détox à un peu de la tourette notre lui
il est pas y pas hyper futé voilà où on
en a trois qui sourde oreille avec
encore en 30 août travers donc voilà on
a les personnes qui sont un petit peu
plus un peu caricaturaux je dirais mais
on est sur la même histoire avec avec
l'ogre à la fin c'est pas si mal être
chez les costumes hauts en couleur les
dialogues cocasses et percutants les
situations délirantes ainsi que
l'interaction forte avec le jeune public
explique le succès du chat botté
une recette gagnante déjà pour le
spectacle le loup est revenu est devenu
signature de la compagnie nomadesk cris
a remis les c'est du comique de
répétition du coup les enfants adorent
puis on les y participent beaucoup et
puis c'est du théâtre il n'y a pas
beaucoup beaucoup de spectacles de
théâtre vraiment à paris pour les
enfants et beaucoup de spectacles
musicaux là on est vraiment que sur du
théâtre c'est un vrai boulevard pour
pour enfants je pense que c'est ça qui
plaît il ya aussi les parents google
beaucoup la compagnie nomade s qui ce
spectacle le chat botté poursuivent leur
tournée en france et la représentation
au théâtre parisien de l'alhambra
jusqu'au 6 mars prochain c'est à présent
à la fin de cette édition merci de nous
avoir suivis tout de suite vous restez
avec nous vous avez rendez vous avec
sephora namani pour qui est ce que votre
magazine culturel sur saint quentin en
yvelines
quant à moi je vous retrouve demain pour
une nouvelle édition du journal je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée